so yesterday we opened the show with
president biden just finishing up some
of his remarks
on his new covid
sort of battle strategy heading into the
new year in the winter
and we praised partially some of what he
said we criticized
partially some of what he said by the
way he got some unexpected praise
from a source that i was not betting
would say something positive or
i guess supportive of joe biden we'll
tell you about that later this hour
but i think part of biden's problem
broadly speaking well
let's start with this and it's a point
that i made here on the radio yesterday
made it again on get failed last night a
different variation of it but it's the
same theme
and i recognize our interview with
governor sununu yesterday he kind of
explained partially why some of this
might be the case but it's still as the
governor said not really an excuse
being almost two years
into a pandemic and seeing i mean what
christine and dan on our team here in
new york they saw long lines
all over manhattan today coming into
work of people waiting trying to get
tested
this is playing out in major cities
across the country there is a huge
shortage of tests for covid which blows
my mind
did we not i saw mark thiessen just
tweeted this earlier did we not just
spend two trillion more dollars
on covid supposedly coveted relief stuff
that was one of our critiques of the
democrats coveted bill when biden came
into office you had trillions of dollars
spent on a bipartisan basis then the
democrats took over all of washington
they wanted to do their own so-called
coveted bill and what did we say on this
program over and over again we said the
problem with this 1.9 trillion is that a
lot of it has nothing to do with covet
or is going to be spent
years from now right they're saying we
need this to keep our schools open
it's like a huge chunk of the money for
schools was going to be spent in 2023
and beyond not related to coven
if they just spent two trillion dollars
on coveted relief at the very beginning
of this year the very beginning of
biden's presidency here we are months
later
and there's a shortage of coveted
testing in multiple major cities around
the country
how is that possible where the hell did
all that money go
it's not fair to blame any president or
any leader for what's happening with
covid everyone's trying to cope and
figure out what to do it's interesting
when it was trump they criticized when
it's ron desantis they criticize
directly at fault blood on their hands
then when the bad news comes
to other places it's sort of like oh
what how unfortunate
that's you know i guess the seasonality
is hitting and we all have to come
together and unite it's a very different
tone
but there are some things as i've been
saying
that the federal government at least has
some control over
having sufficient testing would be one
of them
having a sufficient plan for booster
shots so people don't have to wait weeks
to get them
that would be another one
we know that variants arise right new
variants show up people might get scared
there might be a run on booster shots
from previously hesitant people all of a
sudden they want to do it how is there
not a great plan in place
for people to go out and get tested on
demand for free or for cheap and to get
their booster shot on demand
the ball has been dropped on those
things
we know that there are really good
therapeutics whether it's
antibodies or this new pill it's been a
slow process
there's been an insufficient amount of
those
therapeutics available
where's the operation warp speed on that
stuff
i mean we've heard how many speeches
from joe biden now
about covid speech after speech demand
after demand
shamefest after shame fest wagging his
finger at all these people you got to do
this if you don't do that you're going
to be
suffering in all of it
trillions of dollars spent
and almost two years into this you still
can't get a test and you can't easily
get a booster in a lot of places across
the country how is that not a failure
how is that not a failure
well here's the answer it is
and you've got incoherent messaging from
people at the very top of this thing
starting with the president himself so
he insisted that the lack of testing or
the testing shortfalls right now are not
a failure which you know of course he's
going to say that because it's his
failure
he promised to shut down the virus we
don't even have tests to go around for
people who feel like they might be
symptomatic or needing to go somewhere
and people suddenly saying oh you know
what fine i am going to get boosted oh i
have to wait until january 14th or
whatever
while the death toll has exceeded the
trump era death toll
there's someone in charge and he got
elected on the promise to shut down the
virus
and he's saying oh well these problems
not his fault and part of the reason he
says it's not his fault is because no
one could have anticipated any of this
cut five
i don't think anybody
anticipated that this was going to be as
rapidly spreading as it did
the omicron virus spread even more
rapidly than anybody thought
okay so they say they're caught off
guard by a new variant
even though
how long have they been warning us about
new variants now things change and how
it's like the flu and there's a new flu
shot every year like this is not new
people been screaming about new variants
people have been screaming about testing
capacity including the doctors on this
show for months
i was like oh well who could have seen
this coming well this is the problem for
biden
also yesterday that sound bite was from
yesterday also yesterday was dr rashel
wolenski
dr wolenski runs the cdc in the byte
administration
she was on special report
and here's what she said on the same
exact subject in cut six the speed by
which omicron has um been you know
transmitting has been seen and mirrored
in many other countries and so we've
been watching this carefully we
anticipated this this is what we have
been preparing for there have been
doubling times of this virus in other
countries that have had the virus before
us in the one and a half to three day
range and so okay so she goes on this is
exactly
what we anticipated
and it is what we have been preparing
for her quote
that is the cdc director
there's a direct quote we anticipated
this this is what we have been preparing
for this is exactly what we anticipated
back to back on the same day with the
president sing i don't think anybody
anticipated this
seems like a problem does it not
and then there's something else that
walensky said in response to one of the
questions on special report about
masking in schools and science and data
a bad answer to a good question with a
new development that really cornered her
no wonder she didn't answer the question
well we will get to that when we come
back it's the guy benson show stay tuned